A morning coffee is now almost a luxury for Europeans.
That's according to the Eurostat statistics office.
It's compiled data on the cost of a pick-me-up in the EU.
Coffee prices were up almost 17% in August from last year.
If you don't take it black, the cost of a cup gets even worse.
Fresh whole milk prices jumped by almost a quarter,...
...and sugar was up even more by over a third.
The data showed prices for the staples rose in every EU country bar Malta.
Finns faced the biggest jump for coffee,...
...with prices there up by 43.6%.
In Poland, the price of sugar more than doubled.
Overall inflation in the Eurozone...
...hit a new record high of 10% in September.
Rising food and energy prices were the big driver.